[Musique]
maintenant
pas sûr
il
[Musique]
parce qu'ici
pas de 4 essentiellement de la frontière
[Musique]
mesdames nous accueillons aujourd'hui
une nouvelle résidente à donne et
j'aurais voulu symboliquement parlant
avoir à mes côtés pour l'accueillir les
deux dernières arrivées voilà donc
madame marsan et madame antoine dernière
arrivée à donne et voilà deux dames de
pluie à dawn d'arrivée des nouvelles est
toujours un moment fort chez nous c'est
une religion des femmes
la convention 1909 qu'aux filles qui
donne à fond de cette maison où les
dates du monde un revers de fortune
ces écossais à 100% ils deviennent c'est
vous serez donne au ciel sans pourtant
bientôt c'est très bien je m'appelle
martin g 92 ans j'arrivais ya cinq ans
après la mort de mon mari michel
normalement nous n'aimons pas beaucoup
parlé de nouveau mon mari dans ma petite
fille a beaucoup pas qui j'étais alors
on a fini par céder pourquoi maintenant
parce que donne est en passe de
connaître un grand bouleversement
[Musique]
allez
moi
oh
[Musique]
grâce à quoi marcher vous lis lunettes
bravo comment s'appelle la cathédrale de
paris mes pieds oui
de quelle couleur et l'herbe avec un
crayon très bien
et que porte la reine d'angleterre sur
la tête je suis perdu alors là la route
verte la question précédente de quelle
couleur et l'herbe que porte la reine
d'angleterre sur la tête à chapeau vert
vers
la dernière fois qu'il fait très bien
cette bâtisse avec voilà il ya beaucoup
le carnet match et même pas ce que c'est
de le bottin mondain c'est d'un
dictionnaire
des mandats c'est additionnel de la
noblesse française 5
alors tu es pitre ce que tu es et tu as
une minute les murs des fans des
relations tu as avec une nouvelle
arrivante yennega le bâtiment neuf ça ça
m'exaspère
je vous propose le suivant trouver des
mots comme en cent la lettre s il l est
les champions
alors je mets ça 23 mai de syracuse
sicile
salute salut sérénissime sicilienne
samedi soir de sirocco ça souffle
suzanne simone symphorien solveig super
message sirène suivre sereinement 6
séances de séchage au soleil
soyons stimuler suivons sion et
simplement sans scrupules saluons le
sanctuaire de la suprême sagesse pour
salut signé sophie
maintenant je suis bien amusé
on
m
non
[Musique]
e
il n'y a pas d'homme mais c'est pas
désagréable du tout entre femmes on
reste très coquette une certaine que
quelqu'un mette un johnny taïder en
mettant penh où quelque chose salut à
une certaine tenue vis à vis les autres
[Musique]
moi je m'entends très bien avec les
formes on a on a souvent des
sensibilités qui se retrouvent
[Musique]
autre femme n'y a pas de jalousie a pas
d'histoire
[Musique]
et
on
bon maintenant les tranquilles jusqu'au
1e très bien
[Musique]
m
paris six morts
[Applaudissements]
non
on voulait
d'abord vous remercier de votre
participation active à en juger par les
257 questions qui ont été posées parce
que j'essaie tout compte et
donc comme vous le savez sans doute le
le projet en lui-même consiste à passer
de 32 studio nous avons à l'heure
actuelle à 50 au total
avec cette extension
dans les candidatures que nous avons
aujourd'hui ou dans les semaines ou dans
les mois à venir on ne s'interdira pas
de recevoir
des messieurs
attention attention attention
douche à vous attaquer comme ça
directement ça
[Musique]
on nous dit
caractéristiques et sa merci beaucoup
mais je tiens pas du tout
il y en a déjà avec les manu table de
bridge qui papillonne des yeux qui se
fait dans tous leurs états ça va créer
des portables vive les femmes
non pour vivre ensemble chez manac sur
la vie mais ça va je suis jacques seul à
poser problème
certaines se peut très bien ici
qu'à rigolo en quoi c'est pas des
histoires et moi c'est pas drôle et sion
à la hâte un sens mashing on a tout
donné 90 ans ici les i sur les petites
jalousies et petites mesquineries on les
a eus tout labit on n'a pas du tout
envie de les avoir en rade à la déesse
saturé tirs elle tient pas les coeurs si
vous avez une petite tenue
éventuellement vous du 300 m vous
savez petite tenue sur petite tenue ça
va vous n'êtes pas nues quand j'ai créé
un goûter moi je ne suis plus bonne à
rien
le tout le monde sera content voilà je
moi je suis prêt à satisfaire tout le
monde mais c'est toujours impossibles à
soigner des dames comment manier des
dames c'est pas toujours évident morts
[Musique]
est ce que vous en pensez que des hommes
ont intégré cette maison pour le moins
édifiante un ou deux hommes sur a
complètement perdu ici et moi je leur
conseillerais pas de venir
tout seul si violent coup plusieurs
coupes d'accord mais tout seul non c'est
pas couché c'est comme si une femme se
retrouver dans un milieu d'hommes
complètement mais je suis là ce serait
un peu perdu surtout que maintenant vous
dis là la femme a pris son essor
alors là ils vont pas être non pas de
gâter un dans le canal qui sont ils sont
affolés alsup figure qu'elle voudra
parler des bons hommes qui vont leur
faire la cour rendue et leur ont dit que
ça va être la vente toi parce que voyez
le monsieur avec toutes les dames autour
c'est pas
un homme ici devant un quartier d'homme
ça
ce serait le bordel
je temps en temps dans la tête non non
[Musique]
je suis obligé
en
attendant c'est drôle parce que moi je
les ai jamais vu ces photos
ça sert voilà ça y est ça c'est charmant
si légère si lourde
là il me parle parle elle à table
sans tromper 1940 rock ça c'est parce
que je donne ma belle-mère à l'est c'est
là où j'ai connu michel l aller comme il
est beau il est des fagots
la pratique le mil le but de michel
salle des fêtes de michel
[Applaudissements]
je l'aide à très amoureuse
je vais la pipe le cigare cigarettes on
sait que
ça c'est le travail est justement c'est
la honda
1,70 sur thur mahdieh plus on était
jeune il convient de 19 chefs sa famille
de
50 ans qui était bien
peut-on tout mon enfance je suis né à
sedan de 8 des 110 926 il ya longtemps
et puis après une seule revenu à paris
mais les études qui est chargée des
colts coup deux clans parce que j'étais
pas très sale s'était même insupportable
elle a brillé partout
jusqu'à ce que va mettre en pension
parce que c'est un but très bien quoi
faire de moi
j'étais pas méchante mais j'étais un peu
défini je les bords des devis c'était
surtout ça y est la maison ça s'est
traduit comme ans j'avais les succès
parce que j'étais rigolade que que je
jamais oui j'ai pu déchaîner c'est pas
que c'est à dire s'il y avait des
charges avec plein pot de fleurs on se
disait des choses temps ni vous
embrasser dans le coup sûr vos points
des lèvres et des petits salaires ça
n'est pas plus loin
[Musique]
on a commencé à fréquenter des garçons
je crois que je vais avoir 20 ans
et je quand on commençait allie danse et
parce que ça ça a été notre période
notre c'était notre notre génération ont
dansé beaucoup les jeunes filles avec
des robes de bal comme avant la guerre
et comme le tissu manquer les robes de
bal était quelquefois fait d'un des
rideaux mais quand c'était des beaux
rideaux c'était belle robe de bain
les garçons ne rentrait pas sans cravate
c'était pas le laisser aller ça nous
donnait une ville envie d'être belle
on dansait le tombeau lavage et puis le
good stuff j'avais quand même un
monsieur qui me prenait toujours pour
valser gta spécialistes
parce que je vais être légère
le seul endroit où décembre à six ans
pour nous qui est passé à la cuisine
c'était du forte très petit à petit un
dangereux et très innocent et la plupart
du temps personne n'est pas le rapport
si tu veux me faire dire on ne coûterait
pas les uns et des autres que moulé
jeune bourré de capteurs fire onu
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
bodjoma là j'allais vous dire la
cérémonie a déjà
commencé au nez des dames indignes car
les dames a dit enfin aux âges
les plus graves lyonnais est tellement
sage qui conduit
à leur écoute et je crois que l'heure
est grave parce qu'il faut que je fasse
ses yeux la coque est alors pour les
oeufs à la coque alors pour vous lancer
dans des choses terribles si oui non
mais on peut les rater cet hymne
absolument il faut que je veux rappeler
c'est une chose extrêmement grave alors
martin est ce que vous les aimez le
blanc prix et par le jaune vous me dites
oui ou non non non comme vous avez prévu
tout est violent mais j'ai rien prévu si
vous avez prévu pour l'un pour l'autre
non non non non non non je vous assure
[Applaudissements]
assis et vous regardez cette assiette
martin ok j'ai pesé somptueux
merci moi je vais rester optimistes ils
ont pas faire de mélange kiné mais vous
n'avez pas prendre un taxi pour rentrer
chez vous alors un petit fou
génial les au coke arrêté trey hardee
mais c'est pas facile
vous savez à une demi minute près et il
peut être dur il peut être dur
j'aurais adoré être et à la liste en
angleterre assez amusant étalagiste
alors mon jeu rémy
décoratrice mais à condition d'être
architecte et vous de moi iv la danse
deuxième chose épouse est le même farmer
oui un peu j'aurais aimé jacqueline
je ne connaissais pas jacqueline à
l'époque où ne résident à dorer la vie
le nord-est de la famille qui avait des
propriétés ans
j'avais rarement très votre mari aydin
et il y avait bien trente personnes à ce
dîner il m'a vu à la cheminée il était
en train de parler avec la maîtresse le
médecin a dit qu'il cette fille
là dit mono et ça y est
mais sur sa merveilleuse soirée oui moi
je sais pas dit c'est lui parce que mais
c'est souvent comme ça oui quand l'homme
a fait son choix et décide et puis c'est
un peu dangereux
c'est ce que je vais faire dans c'est
pas évident que d'une bonne voulait pas
de sel
m
[Musique]
e
je racontais mes balles à ma mère et
quand je suis arrivé un soir je unis il
ya un officier qui m'a demandé en
mariage ma mère dit ça y est on va caser
la fille on ma case est littéralement
chagossienne cavalerie qui était beau et
de décoration qui avait fait venir deux
magnifiques et tout
me suis marré il sortait de la guerre la
chose qu'il voulait avant tout c'est se
marier en plus bon je t'ai jeunes
pas trop laide mon père avait un job pas
trop de mal au mois d'avril j'étais
fiancée au mois de mai j'étais mariée et
ne font après j'ai et mère de famille a
été en en un an j'ai vécu ce que les
jeune fille vivait de 14 à 25 ans quand
vous ce complètement inconsciente ça me
pose et le fait qu'on vous est demandée
en mariage que ces anneaux sud cavalerie
tous les choses qui n'existent plus du
tout maintenant c'était très important à
l'époque
je m'entendais très bien mon père est
alors après le voyage de l'osce il était
un peu ému mon père me vois comme ça
alors ou bien leur ma chérie j'adore ça
s'est bien passé
il est gentil temps marie est tout
simple la seule chose que je puis dire
ce qu'il y avait un lustre dans la
chambre qui était parfait qui bougeait
tout le temps mon père du bambin
seger et marianne règne parler du luxe
en 13 qui va dessiner non mais ça fait
rien en traitant mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup de choses elles font ce
qu'elles font avant ce soient des femmes
libres et leurs agents
saisissant
c'est un
à
or
ans
vous savez que j'ai refait un tableau
avec le coq vous ai refait le même sujet
le même sujet mais c'est tout mais je
n'ai pas pas exactement de la même façon
effet les plus mais d'une autre façon et
puis j'ai mis un peu de végétation qui
gémit une poule il coule au milieu tous
les coptes je les fais belle la poule
parce que le côté noir et tout paraît
bel est la lan craindre pour qu'un plus
petit
[Musique]
qu elles sont souvent villa et bulma
pondent des oeufs oui enfin c'est bien
non ils pourront rien n'est faux casse
les oreilles avec ses chants
[Musique]
alors toc toc toc ça c'est bien il faut
les choses en plus maintenant alors là
maintenant oui ce qui m'a vu dans le
bouquet c'est que j'ai dit sur un bout
de faire ici c'est un bouquet qui
raconte une histoire un bouquet car on
ne peut qu ils racontent pas d'histoires
c'est pas bouclé réussi alors là
maintenant il faut que je raconte
histoire
quel est le hasard qui fait qu'ils sont
rencontrés
un jardin parisien
une fleur de banlieue favori dd on peut
s'inventer des histoires merveilleuses
maintenant pour une histoire devient
très intéressante là elle est bien mais
elle est banale bon je mette à tout
hasard une tête de tulipes pour voir ce
que ça donne latulippe tout seul
notre clip tout seul qui a voulu prendre
pour une rose
[Musique]
1 c'est pas mal
vous savez les gens qui n'ont jamais vue
ils n'ont pas de moi nous nous quand on
a vu et quand on voyait très bien ce qui
était mon cas
la mémoire des choses est impérissable
absolument c'est ça qu'on veut c'est de
se dire que rien n'est jamais perdu même
quand on appelle son compte qu'on a tout
perdu
[Musique]
vous voyez la dernière fugue bagatelle
michel on s'est assise à la faveur à
opérer sur sa bonne gestion des codes de
thiviers se répandre autour
du commun
et grand père alors est ce que tu peux
me raconter comment votre histoire et
connaissait le ça m'embête de raconter
pourquoi n'en savons ni pascal quiry les
éditions de rafles de juifs dans la
savane lui de parler de ça parce que
comme tous les bons bourgeois de ses
patins de la plupart du temps il est et
antisémites les juifs on est fréquenté
par les voiliers par les connaissez pas
comme tu m'as j'ai appris deux jeunes
filles jade et camps de concentration
l'élu qui s'est passé pour ces juifs
ça m'a chamboulée complètement c'est
tellement injuste tellement monstrueux
comme carlo lippmann ton grand père m'a
demandé en mariage
d'abord c'était mon meilleur ami je
n'étais pas amoureux de lui c'était mon
meilleur ami en rentrant dans le times a
demandé en mariage je me souviens que tu
m'as demandé mariage dans ma mère j'ai
dit ah merde merde merde merde
et je lui dis non et pour moi il n'était
pas question je m'appelle madame lipman
et c'est moins huit dix mois après qu'il
versait les feignasses dangereux ont par
contre voir j'ai à vous parler et j'ai
réfléchi pendant toute cette période là
en disant que c'était monstrueux elle ma
part mon attitude et deuxièmement
s'étaient passé le mot négatif
deuxièmement
je trouvais que
je ne pouvais pas me passer comprends
pas c'est un type a si brillamment
intelligent il m'avait marqué j'avais
besoin de lui dans ma vie j'ai voyagé
envisagée par amis sont identiques à
londres si vous êtes toujours d'accord
on peut se marier
[Musique]
dans certains drames dans ma famille
parce que j'ai besoin juifs du coup il
me marier à paris maman noyer le poisson
en faisant marièrent sans tremper hills
avec un maillage très gai
[Musique]
je trouve que tu as quand même eu pas
mal de panache pour ton époque mais suez
d'un grille-pain leur esprit
peut-être c'est ça dd va regarder ma
imparfait mais je sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose puisque j'ai divorcé etc
c'est peut-être ça ne se faisait pas
mais je vois qu'il ya une certaine
contradiction des principes de ton
éducation de ton milieu qui sont pas
totalement en adéquation avec la
victoire du psg voilà j'ai tueur et n
qui veut baggaley ou bâle et es13
l'éducation il le fait que j'avais envie
d'envoyer tout péter ses terres en
championnat
tu beaucoup plus sage maintenant c'est
ce que je disais à chippis je suis d'une
sagesse exemplaire comme vieille dame je
n'ai pas été toute ma vie voilà deux
complets relatifs
sur ça c'est un disque est un truc
[Musique]
je suis le ténébreux leboeuf la console
et le pass d'aquitaine à la tour aboli
ma seule étoile est morte et mon lutte
constellé porte le soleil noir de la
mélancolie
j'ai pleuré dans la grotte où nagent la
sirène après je me souviens plus
[Rires]
mignonne et la hausse
après dix semaines
après sa robe pourpre est et son thème
ordres de rabbins
c'est vous qui vont faire un prénom
pierre il l'écrit acquis à cassandre
personnes sont amoureuses
[Musique]
en
55 ans de mariage oui
j'ai eu un homme dans ma vie et c'est le
seul et l'unique là il restera unique
jusqu'à jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
[Musique]
il avait des beaux yeux il avait des
yeux magnifiques
peut-être un brin tout noir tout bien
bronzé on a parlé alors il m'a dit voilà
je suis je suis marin je l'aimé a
raconté un petit peu en dansant puis
après on est sorti on est sorti du
dédain si il y avait un petit récent un
petit bar en face et on est allé
s'asseoir dans ce bar en a commandé une
menthe à l'eau je me rappelle voyez il
m'a ramené jusqu'à chez moi et il est
parti avec les mon adresse dans ses
poches et ça ça a duré voilà et vous
savez on s'est écrit tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours on se découvre et à travers mais
être créés chéri depuis quelques jours
nous marchons par service sur les deux
jours nous pouvons écrire que le soir il
arrive que je sois de cas à ce moment là
je puis répondre à certaines de vos
lettres à l'époque il me voyait encore
et que que je ne manque pas de faire le
lendemain j'ai hâte de vous sert n 1
vous étouffez je ne ferai pas donc c'est
des choses très
réservé
c'est loin tout ça
le temps a passé
mais comme on dit les souvenirs restent
et c'est bien
[Musique]
oh
c'est à vous ah oui c'est d'ailleurs
voulait pas aller à toulouse l'étude
bien un petit peu et moi en ce moment où
je viens pas pour mourir parce qu'aux
stations qui s'amuse ça tourne ben je
vous ramènerai dans votre habitude
[Musique]
vous avez fêté ça elle vous vous rendez
compte
j'avais fêté sans à elle
que vous avez fait est essentielle sans
noël sansan de rage qui chante 95 96 97
je lui ai fêté sans noël si la main oui
oui bah oui vous avez 100 ans
vous avez fait
le risque
monstre émetteurs de papiers de finale à
aguas tradition serra de sa boîte et
rabih chez nous et évaluer des kleenex
génial
voilà et ses leçons tirez le fonds et
vous mettez votre boîte de kleenex
[Musique]
ces couplets je vais vous demander un
petit peu d'attention vous savez que la
fondation à
repenser ses statuts il ya maintenant
trois ans alors il est vrai que depuis
1909 les statuts étaient prévus pour
accueillir que des dames qui étaient des
femmes ou veuves ou fille d'officier
depuis peu nous pouvons accueillir des
hommes et ce que je voulais partager
avec vous c'est que ce projet est en
voie d'aboutir est en voie d'aboutir et
demain je dois recevoir un monsieur qui
seraient intéressés pour entrer dans la
maison dans un avenir assez proche
grâce à nos non non non non et non il
est tout sauf grain chaud alors ce
monsieur était chirurgien voit la suisse
qu'il aimerait c'est garder son
indépendance mais ils recherchent du
lien il a envie de pouvoir échanger il
n'a pas envie de rester seul chez lui il
est veuf depuis un an donc le projet lui
correspond vous voyez vous n'avez pas de
problèmes il y en à peine 6 ans voire
d'amour et pourquoi pas pour le mariage
et bouraba et je salue des lots
téléréalité
grandirait jours on va pas essayer de
s'en accaparer pour la loi soit et alors
j'attends pour voir je voudrais ce que
j'en pense ça existe quand même votre
curiosité oui
mais non je sais pas comment il est
alors sous bada
saura-t-il vous séduire
bien sûr je défends n'importe qui
elle agit là à 94 ans pardon
et très agir tout du sondage c'est très
avait chez madame l'antenne c'est très
âgées dans la conférence est 4
par les
fans tchèques qui publie maintenant aux
commandes d'apple
bref c'est du parti qui s'est prouvé les
infirmières sur place
megan
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
non
oui
la bagarre
[Musique]
à
pour l'allemand
[Musique]
oh
le temps
[Musique]
oh
un
jour on va s'installer dans le salon oui
regardez
aujourd'hui rentrer dans une maison où
il n'y a que des femmes pour le moment
où seriez le premier homme à donne c'est
quelque chose qui vous non plus alors
aux relations que cliff hammonds et et
de simplicité
comme femme j'ai eu ma femme
idéale dans cette charge est elle à dire
c'est
formidable
et aujourd'hui vous avez des questions
en particulier les déviations avaient
opposé jeudi soir au cosec fait
d'ailleurs une petite liste parce que
c'est
est ce qu'il ya un règlement intérieur
oui il ya un règlement intérieur elle
absolument la surveillance médicale vous
aviez des bracelets entité au sein des
différents soit le coiffeur de
kinésithérapie les pédicures l'usep
quels sont les frais non compris dans le
forfait mensuel et des questions très
précises à
des questions très précises pour très
pratique le lièvre est
abbaoui
j'ai répondu à toutes vos questions
si j'habite ici ça ne va pas tu veux
rentrer chez moi c'est possible ah bah
non non non c'est pas possible pas
passer ma ba non non je rigole bien sûr
que c'est possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wii party
il était là on est heureux de nous
appeler parce que ça c'est une
distraction
je rappelle j'étais là là là était
devant la au premier plan ah ben oui
mais pourquoi lui enlever ses vêtements
il avait juste une petite manchette avec
trois petites feuilles ah oui c'est ça
je trouve qu'il ya plus de flair à
droite qu'à gauche we are one flirt ce
côté-ci pas parce que parce qu'il ya
autre chose mais là c'est un pied de nez
au milieu où il va vouloir après c'était
la citronnelle et pas avant
c'est horrible je comprends pas à mon
avis comme dit je sais pas qui
[Musique]
procès du chiffre
visés par des mandats donnés oui je
parle l'hexagone est normalement oui
c'est bon est ce que tout le monde même
temps vous allez fermer mes yeux deux
secondes
parce que nous sommes en
elle est trop grosse elle est trop
intelligent talent est trop onéreuse
elle est trop aimante
voilà une femme qui a déjà posé les
prémices de la démocratie les prémices
de la littérature romantique que le
repas tel acte elle connaît que l'europe
politique connell que l'on connaît que
l'on aime en angleterre que l'on admire
en autriche en prusse en italie en
espagne sera madame de st c'est un
monument historique
absolument admiré de tous genres a pas
deux comme ça dans l'histoire de france
elle a commencé par afficher des idées
extrêmement d'avant garde c'est
l'ennemie numéro 3 de napoléon elle va
payer des geôliers à la cire pour faire
ses bad et beaucoup de femmes qui
échapperont à la guillotine comme ça
permettre de ce stade là 45 ans et là
elle rencontre un garçon qui à 23 ans un
magnifique garçon bouclé brens et a eu
sa il est jeune il est ignorant on le
dit un peu saut et n'a jamais ouvert un
livre et tombe follement amoureux de
cette femme et c'est un véritable amour
elle est attendri ému par ce parfum
en fait il est là il est là il lui prend
la main sauf au temps de s'asseoir au
bord de son lit lui prendre la main de
lui embrasser un peu les bras
c'est tout ce qui se permet de fermer
les follement amoureux vous rendez
compte de ce trentenaire bon et cette
femme tombe amoureuse à son tour de ce
garçon qui ont pu s'y tuberculeux et des
peut marcher qu'avec une béquille
tellement il a été blessé ce n'est pas
la moitié des veaux quel emploi il
comprend pas bon quand elle dit quelque
chose il rougit pas leamy comprends pas
ils répondent pas tellement m par contre
elle dit cette phrase ravissante elle
dit la parole n'est pas son langage
alors là car le train de vous voir
courir
séverine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
je
chaque année j'ai lancé mes courriers
nouveau pour noël les dates des cours et
je reprenais offrons ce dessin de jeunes
filles
tout petit j'ai commencé à danser tous
les dimanches était sacré pape avait
fait faire un appareil musicale très
remarquable faisait ressortir les bases
et tout est donc l'après midi c'était
une tradition papam été souvent du
wagner méduses bussy duravel en photo
les compositeurs de l'époque où si
merveilleux wagner était le fond et de
danser seul dans le salon quand papa
mettait de la musique
quand j'ai fini mon gars chaud j'ai créé
ma propre école de danse et beaux jours
il y avait à
chorégraphe que je connaissait m'a vu
danser il m'a dit voilà je vais vous
engager comme soliste dans ma troupe et
nous partons en amérique latine mais à
ce moment là j'avais rencontré mon futur
époux
et il fallait que je choisisse entre le
mariage et la danse
pas évident
finalement je me suis dit je peux pas le
laisser passer si je lui dis non bah ça
sera fini et ben voilà c'était un peu
difficile mais je ne regrette rien
[Musique]
mon rêve c'était une grande table un
lustre qui descendent sa lumière sur la
table mon mari en face de moi que je ne
connaissais pas je vais pas encore
démarré et plein d'enfants tout autour
c'était mon rêve comme moi j'avais perdu
ma mère très petit c'était mon rêve et
je les réalise aimons réjoui alors
évidemment les femmes ne travaillait pas
très peu travaillé j'ai pas de souvenir
d'amy qui travaille et on travaillait
après leur mariage
j'adore la maison alors ça ça m'a
beaucoup occupé j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses moi-même les rideaux d'études
l'idée tape il tape des coussins des
jets recouvert des meubles j'ai fait des
choses comme ça et puis comme mon mari
est mort ma fille m'a dit maman vous
devriez faire ce que vous ne pouviez pas
faire quand vous étiez mariée
et je suis très contente montant est
libre en ce moment c'est ça qui est
merveilleux
[Musique]
ma
quelquefois je me dis qu'est-ce que
j'aurais pas pu avoir une vue plus
intelligente plus positif + plus
efficace plus
que qui aurait laissé des traces utile
voyez ce que je veux dire plus utile
aussi évidemment élever ses enfants
c'est très utile aujourd'hui c'est
dommage je me les élèves pas assez mais
j'aurais aimé créer quelque chose pour
ça qu'à travers la peinture je trouve
quand même de la satisfaction
[Musique]
tout ça c'est des concurrents
qui attend de chacun en retire chacun
son tour
mais vous êtes à cette femme tellement
vous êtes la seule femme
bun peut-être bien oui oui
c'est la première fois où j'ai tiré
c'était c'était en picardie
j'avais battu les hommes là c'est quand
on est encore plus fier j'étais très
bonne tout ça c'est tout ça c'est les
prix que de gagner
comme enfant on a été 5 gt la troisième
fille depuis la première mon père
voulait un un garçon et il a dit
carrément merde quand je suis arrivé
il avait une cravate chose qui était
cavalier militaire
alors si j'avais si j'avais disputé
après ma soeur il me faisait mettre par
terre comme le tapis la et émeut
cravacher le dos
mon père ses théâtres je suis admirative
devant lui mais je peux vous dire que je
n'aime pas du tout
parce qu'il a été très méchant huit mois
et a trouvé de traumatiser le restant de
ses jours avec ce qu'il a fait et à 18
ans je me marier
parce que j'avais envie de partir
justement
j'aimais c'était le sauveur
en en
il est certain que mon enfance ma marque
est quand même mais maintenant tout
maintenant tout ça c'est oublié mais
j'aime j'aime plutôt me laisser faire
maintenant maintenant je trouve que ça
suffit
oui
[Musique]
oh
vous
[Musique]
l'appareil qu'on l'ait pas fait
non
j'aime bien passé
la daurade
voilà est-ce que tout le monde voit
mylène
avant d'en venir aux remerciements à
proprement parler j'aimerais qu'à
l'occasion de votre départ en retraite
nous ayons une pensée reconnaissante et
ému envers toutes les femmes qui comme
vous mylène
sont arrivés et arrive encore
aujourd'hui en france dans des
conditions souvent dramatiques et font
preuve d'un courage remarquable
ayant fui un régime communiste dans les
conditions que nous connaissons tous
vous avez fait partie de ce que la
presse française de l'époque a appelé
les boat people en quelque 5000 journée
de travail combien de repas servis
combien de pas de kilomètres de couloirs
des escaliers combien d'efforts
d'engueulades de sourires et de main
tendue merci je vous embrasse
on a toutes les dames se sont réunis
pour vous offrir ce modeste mais se
présente pour vous merci pour ce que
vous êtes un petit peu je vous aide
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas chinois ces vietnamiens
on n'a pas de point on n'a pas le droit
au pain ou d'un proche ou non moi j'aime
bien du père mais bon la cuisine saine
orient parce qu'on sait pas comment
comprendre
qu est ce qui vient de m'envoyer du site
on
balaye saviez-vous perd 20
ça correspond aux faits revient à jean
pour les jeunes alors que ça a été des
drames
dans les livres d'histoire mais et
regarder la guerre de 39 40 et la gère
14 ans lit d'histoire moi j'ai vu ça
avec mes petits-enfants juste incroyable
séché résumer comme ça quand on pense qu
on a vécu ça que nos parents vécu ça et
qu'on voit ça en peu de lignes dans un
lieu d'histoire farol et ça m'a fait un
coup ce type d'histoire vous savez
[Musique]
patrice
maman ou que tu mets ça sur la bonne
liste maintenant je m'inquiète un peu de
voir que j'ai des petites filles de 32
ans 30 ans candy affective est important
de ne se marie pas qu'ils n'ont pas pris
une décision qui ont pas plus
d'entraînement dans l'ami
je sais pas quand ils vont se décider à
faire des enfants à et ont fait
plusieurs essais en fait des 17 de l'île
maritalement qui on change de partenaire
et alors comment si on sent des corps à
droite à gauche ont fini par soigner je
ne sais pas quel âge ça me paraît
incroyable mais ce que tu trouves que
c'était mieux que de se marier à 19 ans
sans rien connaître de la vie est tombée
enceinte
eh ben vous la fidélité dans les couples
y en avait pas un ton époque
si j'ai les familles à la mairie fermée
chez les femmes parce que vous risquez
de tomber enceinte davantage mais ça
n'avait pas été le cas tu vois et puis
je connais un peu
les couples heureux et merveilleux parce
qu on se mariait 19 ans s'était pas du
tout ça tu vois donc je suis pas
d'accord avec cette manière de projeter
parce que vous aviez peut-être pas le
choix mais c'était n'étaient pas idéales
donc à l'heure actuelle il s'agit
d'autre chose je suis sûr que ta mère se
serait retourné dans sa tombe de te voir
divorcée elle n'a jamais admis la grande
loi de 75 qui a permis quand même
fondamentalement d'élargir le divorce et
tout ça en a profité de cette libération
des moeurs ça n'était qu'une certaine
mais je suis pour une certaine
libération démarche n'est pas passé le
cap mais maintenant oui c'est marrant je
les choix des enfants et des petits
enfants se portent sur autre chose motta
et héritier de mes choix au meeting moi
je sais que nos enfants sont souvent là
pour nous
pour nous bouger pour nous remuer pour
nous
parfois nous bouleverser sur les des
modes de vie des attitudes et de
réflexion qui effectivement sont pas
directement issue nous ils sont pas clos
n'y pensent pas comme nous lorsque je
gagne à maman se l'était dit exactement
le contraire je pense qu'avec l'âge tu
es devenu beaucoup plus ouverte et
tolérante
film ma mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mai 68 qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour
je pensais qu'il y avait
qu avait des raisons
qu'il fallait un peu bousculer les
choses je comprenais très bien la femme
qui désiraient avoir sa place dans la
vie voilà
tout simplement ça est reconnue d'avoir
de sortir de son carcan
d'avoir des enfants quand elle le
voulait
et puis
décider de sa vie c'est tout c'était pas
encore c'est ce qu'on raconte maintenant
là comme on l'a
pas là pour discuter mais il a la même
chose les gars l'illégalité ou je sais
pas quoi comment ça s'appelle l'égalité
hommes femmes oui oui la parité c'est ça
je cherchais oui c'était pas encore du
tout la parité à cette époque là et
c'est cool aspect positif dans ma
génération de femmes peut-être le fait
que vous construisez votre vie vraiment
alors que le la soumission sans amertume
137 une importante de la soumission un
peu on était beaucoup plus de pays sans
que vous ne l'étiez
on l'abbaye c'est elle sur libre c'est
très bien mais comment plus elle garde
les traditions d'avant c'est à dire de
se marier et d'avoir des enfants
ça devient des vicois je trouve
difficile alors est ce qu on les réussit
sévices difficile il y en a qui les
réussissent très bien
très bien et puis pour certains d'un son
à son des bordels sont son n'y arrive
pas pour quelle lagarde cette liberté et
qu'elle se bat pour ça c'est très
important
parce que elle est l'égal de l'homme
mais non dans tous les domaines
quoi qu'on en dise elle et elle est
égale l'homme mais
elle peut faire elle peut aller au bout
de son rêve et de ce qu'elle a décidé
ces six
là bas
[Musique]
ap
10 12
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
je peux vous dérange et y aller suer
visiter la maison il ya les venues par
d'autres se seraient big eyes est sorti
c'est pas toi j'ai couru ici sur le
jardin et de la persuasion du studio de
l'autre côté sont ravis parce qu'elle
ton soleil le matin et c'est vrai elle
les jantes chalets et les matins nous
l'avons l'après-midi les gants leur
avantage au oui oui oui c'est pas tout à
fait et puis alors vous avez à la porte
et vous le vous pouvez montrer mashaal
cobayes c'est un refus d'une femme dort
c'est en envisagée seulement j'avais
peur j'ai beaucoup de défauts mais d'une
part tenait à bout pour les salles de
bains sont à peu près avec une salle de
douche avec un siège les toilettes tarn
lorsque vous jouez oreilles tu fais
chier non alors j'ai joué mais j'avais
trois heures de plus jovial mais
bon après muse est alors classé
bombardier sans bridge mais je vous
verrai peut-être tout à l'heure
à l'est
dommage pour sûr monsieur deux matches
on peut rentrer entrez entrez et bien
vous voyez mon studio monsieur vu depuis
six ans je suis bien je suis bien voilà
important de dire ça mais oui mais je
vous dis très franchement je suis bien
je suis tranquille nous sommes
débarrassés de beaucoup de petites
choses ennuyeuse ah
ah oui bon je lis beaucoup plus depuis
je suis si moi je lis beaucoup je
pouvais pas le faire avant j'étais des
rangées occupées etc enfin voila mais
c'est tout et c'est tout à fait mon cas
bon eh bien si l'on ne peut plus rien
faire tellement on a deux choses à faire
dans la vie courante wip et des petites
choses à ce moment ci voilà on est bien
sur le jardin non je suis pas sur le jeu
au sol un je suis sur la rue j'entends
quelques fois par les chantant une moto
guilers et j'entends la vie once moins
de solitude oui j'entends la vie et
j'aime bien entendu je comprends voilà
vous avez déjà visité intitulé j'habite
je ne me rendais pas compte des volumes
si vous voulez savoir ce qu'on peut mais
je vois que vous avez un lit
relativement étroit oui ah oui oui les
grands lits dévore ses petits souliers
voilà alors un livre des petits meubles
une bibliothèque c'est important oui oui
louis la possibilité de chercher le
livre valable pour la phrase trop chargé
vous savez les livres sont des amis
alors on aime bien les avoir avec soir
je prends ça très bien
et puis j'ai une table vous aimé
recevoir oui sujet voilà j'ai souvent
quelqu'un à dîner alors j'achète à dean
étouffé puis road in sur la table
alors monsieur je vous dis à bientôt
j'espère fait bien sûr moi aussi chez
soleil enfin monsieur
parle d'un table merci nous avoir reçu
le matin
voilà c'est la dernière journée vous
pourrez bronzer au soleil
bonzi au fait vous ne savez pas des
ae vous folle il faut de la crème oui
on va où là naturel mais bien la bévue
pense que le monsieur lucarne à notre
besoin martine elle a le privilège de
voir qu'après vous l'avez vu il est
passé là il a vu mon poisson en bouchant
d'un match
avant l'heure mais vous entendez ça dans
sa chambre il est trop petit pour vous
vous beauchamp il va être très petit
pour nous parce que vous vous êtes très
grand vous êtes contente oui
contentin martine aubry je vous laisse
il ya des beaux yeux
des messieurs ne sais pas vous savez
quand tu rentres fait pas comme dirait
que je ne sais pas tout alors monsieur
il se rend pas compte ou il arrive
tout seul dans une maison dont un oui ça
m'étonne pas de vous
mêmes on connaît pas on kitchenette à
[Rires]
venir marseille
[Musique]
on
oh
cette année marque la voilà une qui
arrivent sur notre gamme
tu vois pas rien
[Musique]
on
grand-mère 60 ans nous séparent c'est
tout un monde
[Musique]
j'admire ton indépendance d'esprit tu as
vivacité la façon dont tu as su se
départir des carcans de tous milieux ton
élégance tapis d'heure ton humour la
modernité
la liberté
[Musique]
c'est beau ça c'est très beau tu vois on
marche on peut aller à pied c'est ce que
vous êtes tous les jours avec une chaîne
de l'hôtel je parle avec arthur et steve
se promenait puis enflammé en vouliez au
soleil
son écriture
voilà
[Musique]
à
vous avez le temps de réfléchir à vos
projets olala arrêt
mon coeur balance
oh
[Musique]